I just think we don't live in
we just get away with it because we
don't face consequences for anything
it's like there's so many Sims that'll
put up with disrespectful behavior and
still date them and still marry them
still give them children when they don't
respect them I mean how many times we
hear happy wife happy life how many
times we hear she wears the pants in the
relationship is that a relationship any
woman really wants to be in where she's
like exactly they're end up divorcing
them and then we're in the same cycle
when a guy wants to make a decision like
she'll call him toxic and controlling I
mean I hear it all the time on the show
if he asks you to take down your social
media he's toxic and controlling when
that's actually quite reasonable to not
want random men looking at your girl on
the internet